In the camera, I think it looks more like peach.
Oh yeah, that's true. These days, especially because it's dirty nowadays and the yellow lighting.
Yeah, maybe. Yeah, just like my shortcut or I mean, it's little.
What color is it?
I'm not able to recall. I think it's a little bit...
Purplish, but maybe you may see it white, my shirt color.
For what?
Oh yeah, it does look white in the lighting. Like an off-white, grayish color.
Yeah.
Yeah, I think these camera qualities are not, you know, that I could add, you know, just like our, you know, cell phone cameras or DSLRs.
Yeah, well that and then like any, like yellowing you have to your screen that you don't notice, but it's like there.
Oh, nice. How are your dogs?
Oh, you know, be in pains, be in pains, but they're cute, so.
I forgot how many of these are.
Two of them.
Okay, which breed?
Yeah.
German Shepherd and Husky Shepherd mix. So they keep me busy. Yeah.
Oh, wow.
Yeah.
German shepherds are common in India as well, but...
D.
We do have huskies, but they are not that common. Well, I like huskies more. No discrimination, although I mean with animals, but you know I like them more.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, my husky has three legs too, so he's a tripod. He's so cute.
Hey, Rick.
Oh, okay.
Hey, Rick, like was running.
Everyone.
Eric.
All right.
So thank you. Yeah, thank you. Welcome everyone for this call. And I think if you're good to start, so shall we, Kevin, anything from your end before we start or Rick?
No, no, we can start. Thanks.
Yeah.
All right, thank you. And we're all we good to see the presentation? Okay, thank you.
Yep.
Team, so let me know once is there on your screens.
Is it?
Yes.
Here we can see it.
Thank you. All right, so...
The main screen from graphical standpoint is still the same. We have not made much changes to it except the...
the details. So it is for the last two weeks from June 15th to 26th, which we'll be reviewing in this period. And I don't have to say it, but I do say it, but please feel free to chime in whenever you have any questions, any feedback, any observations, you know, during this time.
And we would love to hear from you.
So agenda items are going to remain the same. We have highlights, performance analysis, ITBD service offerings, AI by design, holiday schedule, wave forward with uptime USA, and of course, recap, which I'll also be sharing after this call along with.
Minutes of meetings.
I captured some of these highlights from, these are my observation, but Amber, I would love to hear from you as well. So I'm glad that the 3rd edition, Santos, he successfully got on board with your team. And
So anything about, I think you work closely with all the parts, right? So.
So, anything about center?
Yeah, I mean like daily meetings and like chats. I haven't had any feedback from like regarding Santos and stuff. So I feel like he's probably finding his way around pretty easily then I don't see too much like chatter from him and everything in a sense, which sometimes that's good. That means they're, you know, finding their way around and
Mm.
like getting acclimated.
Okay, thank you for sharing that.
And we'll be viewing further. So Sher met his utilization target, which means time, productivity in this period. And Phoebe worked on 43 tickets more than the previous period. So I think we know that. It's just that because she is picking.
less cherry picking. She's not doing much of user onboarding tickets, so at least I think one on an average she's picking up, but not in a two or three in a day. So which is why her ticket work number has improved drastically. And yes, she has also improved her ticket resolve rate.
by 5.86%, although she's going to meet the ITBD target, which is higher. We want our team members to touch at least 80%. So she's still lagging, but I'm glad to see that she's making progress and she has shown some improvement.
from previous number to this number. Anything about Shibi or Phoebe?
Not too much. One thing I would say after our last conversation, I know we spoke about the fact that they have an internal like escalation kind of process they're supposed to follow. And there are times I do notice where it seems like actually both of them do tend to reach out about
Mhm.
questions that might be a little bit more, that could be internal escalation things. Phoebe could also maybe use a little bit more training on like email issues. It seems to be the one she needs to reach out about the most are email issues and things like that. So, and there are times where she'll reach out for questions because someone's like not getting an email, for example.
And my first question will be like, have you checked the email logs? And usually that answer has been no a few times. So yeah, maybe just a bit more on the email training, but it's good. Like she has a good process and I like that she asks questions, but at the same time, sometimes a bit more work on her own before asking that or something would be helpful as well.
Mm-hmm.
Absolutely. So, yeah, this is exactly, you know, what we encourage our engineers. Well, thank you for sharing this. So, because they work, although they're in my team, but they work closely with you the entire day for 9 hours. So, thank you for sharing this, and we'll definitely. So,
You know, I'll share this feedback and work with Phoebe accordingly that this is, you know, we always emphasize with our team, you do your due diligence before you get to the next level, before you seek any assistance from anyone, because you should always have some points handy.
What do you have done? It saves, you know, time of the other people at the same time, because, you know...
Everyone has their precious productive time.
Mhm.
So, we should be ready with our specific questions. I mean, it's the other person here shouldn't be really down to each and every troubleshooting step to find out where exactly the other person is stuck. You know, thank you for sharing this. Any other thing, Amber, you might have observed?
No, otherwise, they both do a great job. They work well with the teams. They're eager to volunteer and take things on when asked. So that's all been really helpful.
Mhm.
Thank you.
Moving on to the next slide, performance analysis.
Okay, so you can see from June 1st to 12 and then 15 to 26. So we'll talk about 1st 15 to 26. So the first two bars are of Phoebe should remain 65, 65 billable, you know, numbers and then non-billable remain.
Twenty percent in the 1st and 19% the second, and overall his ticket resolve rate remain eighty-six and eighty-three, so she's she's meeting her ticket resolve rate target, and yeah, so eighty-four.55% is the total ticket resolve rate that Phoebe has shown.
And she showed 99, sorry, this, I'm sorry, this is not taking result, this is a build by utilization. I'm sorry, I thought I'm already on the next slide.
Yeah.
So, so Phoebe's billable and non-available total utilization is eighty-four.55%, and so I asked, you know, she and Phoebe both that, you know, why there's a drastic difference, so I came to know because...
She.
Phoebe, I was about to say Shivi. Okay, Phoebe, because she was doing more of a user onboarding tickets, which is why, I mean, she was entering, she was subjectual of entering more time in the tickets. So now, since, you know, those tickets, she's doing less as of now.
And she's doing more of, I would say, break-fix tasks. So she was under the impression that, you know, am I entering more time than, you know, she's supposed to be entering? So she said, I'm entering lesser time. Most of the time, you know, do not include my research time.
So, maybe on a on a ticket where the issue to resolve an issue, it took thirty-five minutes, but she was not she she had not been entering her rehearse time, which is 10 to 12, maybe 15 minutes, so she's only she was only entering 20 minutes.
S.
So which is why you may see that our billable numbers are showing only 84.55%, otherwise they might have gone higher. So I gave her the feedback that I understand break fix task should be completed, should not be taking more than 30 to 35 minutes on an average.
I mean, if you're able to resolve much quicker, I mean, 15 or 20 minutes, that's good, but it should not be exceeding 30 to 40 minutes. But it does not mean that if you were able to resolve a ticket within 30 minutes, then you still need to show that, oh, you completed that in 15 minutes and you're not mentioning your research time.
So she should me mention that. Any observation from your end, if I'm correct or you have a different process.
No, I can actually work with her. I think so. I do know Brandy recently had found some time entries where Shiv was putting his time in, but the actual, so like we have the internal like facing notes and then like the customer facing notes. The customer facing ones are required. So like, you know, they have to have something in that box.
Mhm.
Whereas the internal doesn't have to have something in it. And Shiv, I found out, was a little worried about some of the information conveying it to the customers or whatever. So he would put like just a period under the customer facing and then put everything under internal notes. So I know Brandy talked to him about that and adjusting it. And I can work with both of them on how like,
the best ways to do that. Like if she's worried about the customer seeing research time, you know, that's a great thing to like do on the internal notes. Spend, you know, 15 minutes of time reviewing IT glue before calling, asking this and that, like gathering details, which is always, you know, if it takes a little bit longer because you don't know the customer environment.
Mhm.
and you need to do some research on it, we totally get that, you know, so I can definitely work with her on showing her how like she puts it under internal notes, it allows that time to still be captured and like us internally to see what it like, why it might have taken longer than we could expect. But then the customer doesn't see it, so she doesn't have to worry about that.
I was going to talk to Shiv about like the same thing, just so he knows that most things, if you're worried, you can be pretty generic, you know, and things like this, depending on the situation. So I can work with both of them, hopefully before my time off next week. And then this way, just kind of give them some pointers on better ways to do those time entries to help them capture that time.
Yeah, thank you, Amber. Yeah, it's more, you know, more of like, you know, process-related thing. They know they have performed, you know, this much of time, but they just didn't know that whether it should go to internal or whether they should mention or should not mention. For instance, I was discussing a few tickets wherein
VPN related issue of girls INC company that you have.
Girls Inc.
Yeah, Girls Inc. So there was a VPN kind of problem, you know, she was discussing. I mean, it took longer. So he said, I mean, I mean, I had to, you know, go back and forth with internal team and we also needed to, you know, check with the POC at the client end.
Yeah!
Mhm.
Yeah, that was, that's one of those that's, that was a fun one because we didn't have it. We have someone asking for a VPN because they used to have one a long time ago and they didn't have it anymore. We found out. I was like, wait a second, this isn't even turned on. What am I thinking? Why is it even in here still? Yeah, some of those take a little longer to figure out because, and then others are,
Rule and everything.
Yeah.
Yeah, and there was one, and...
You know, and then we have so many clients too. We totally get that you might be working on a client for the very first time. And we always encourage taking 10 to 15 minutes to look in IT glue or do some things to go in prepared, even if it takes a little longer going in prepared and making sure you capture that time is important for them, you know. So
Yeah.
I'll let them know like better ways they can make sure they're doing that with those internal notes and everything as well.
Yes.
Yeah, thank you. Because whenever I connect, so I always discuss the pain areas where they need improvement. For instance, I always ask them, OK, so thank you. We already fixed one thing that is a user onboarding ticket. So that is that was a time consuming thing. So we have curbed.
that situation. The other thing I ask is, tell me those tickets wherein you entered, you took more than 35 to 40 minutes. So I check on here, review only those tickets. So one of them was very strange. File, save on L Drive. That was the summary of the ticket from Life House.
So that user said, to show, walk me through the steps. You give me the training, you know how to do this. I mean, I don't want you to resolve the problem, but even if you resolve this, so you walk me through, I mean, how I should be doing this going forward. So he said, I mean, it took time to, and there was an elderly person.
Maybe. So, yeah, so these are some of the exceptional cases sometimes.
Yeah.
Exactly. You know, in the MSP world, you work with people that I helped someone earlier today for an onboarding and they were a consultant and I know they have a Mac device. Well, first thing I know when I'm going in to help a Mac user is either they don't know technology at all, or they're going to be pretty savvy with it. There's not usually an in-between with a Mac user. Sure enough, he was savvy with it. But
You just, you know, sometimes you don't know what you're going into. That appointment could have taken an hour, depending on how it went. It was done in 20 minutes. You know, just sometimes in the MSP world, you get those curve balls.
Absolutely. And I remember, I remember some of the stories, you know, when I was working with Dell International Services, and I know, so most of the users, you know, needed to have a Dell computer for us to support them. But sometimes, you know, we needed to go an extra mile, so they would say that, oh, you know, I do also have a Mac computer. Can you please, you know, help me with that, connecting your Dell printer with that? So sometimes we used to
Keeps your day interesting, at least.
A struggle, because we were expert on Dell machines and they bring up their Mac computers, and so when we were walking through the steps or we were trying to resolve a problem, sometimes they were more tech savvy, they were asking, they were asking us to, "Okay, can you please go to the Apple icon, then go to File, then go to Desktop, go to App Store, and...
Mhm.
know, download this particular app and do this. So I mean, that was a kind of awkward, embarrassing situation sometimes that the user himself is guiding the technician, you know, what needs to be done. All right, so thank you. So, well, thank you. I think this can be taken care of. So you will discuss with both of these.
Yeah.
teammates. So Shu, I think he did well. So his billable number remained 80% in the first week of, I mean, not first week exactly, I would say from 15th to 19th of June. And his non billable remained 20%. So he was able to meet his total utilization of 100%.
And this is exactly what we want.
Ohh.
I have one question. Do you have any mechanism to, I know engineer is busy, technician is busy the entire day. They should not be worrying about idle time. But if they have, if they have, let's say, lesser ticket and they are not getting any internal tasks from your end.
And they have complete idle time for, let's say, 30 minutes. So how should they be?
showing up that in your PSA tool.
Let me touch base with Brandy and see what sorts of internal like tasks we can like have out there and things like that because I'm not the best at coming up with the internal cleanup type tasks that can get done. But I do know there's probably plenty of little things that we have that we can.
kind of have out there somewhere or like kind of show them what they can do and things like that.
Okay. And Brady, do you, sorry, Amber, do you also allow technicians to do board reviews right in the beginning of their shift? You know, where they can spend 5 to 10 minutes to review the boards? What are the tickets they have on their board? What needs to be scheduled at what time? You know, as per the
Priority of the ticket, maybe, or maybe aging, so, so...
Yeah, we have internal like project tasks essentially where we go, but they're in a separate area, so they might not realize where those are at. I can double check and see if they've put any time on that. But we do have these tickets that are meant to be open and where we kind of dump those like internal time tracking type things for
Mm-hmm.
Mhm.
Careless.
Yeah.
our own board review or if there's internal meetings for any reason. Like these meetings, for example, are tracked for me under this sort of thing. Let me see here for them. Because they might, like I said, it's an actual hour. So there's some in here for Phoebe at some point, but it could have been a while.
Yeah, you know, after speaking to both of these, I think she was doing it. Yeah, I think once or twice a week.
And then Shiv, Shiv has very little also, so, but they both have very little time in these. So it is possible that they're not as familiar with like where these are. They're easy to miss and forget about. So I can remember.
Yeah.
Remind both of them where these were as well.
Sure, thank you. Yeah, this may not be needed every day, but when they have at least, let's say, four to five or more tickets in their bin, they need to, as soon as they log in, they just need to go through and prioritize those tickets accordingly so that they can handle them accordingly.
A schedule as per user's preference or schedule.
So, so Phoebe, you know, as you observed very well, so she was reluctant in entering those times. Sometimes, you know, she gets very conscious about, you know, entering time that, you know, she should not be looked down upon for those things.
Yeah, it doesn't look like she knows about this office administration ticket, which is like what like would go for like board review or things like that. So I can remind her where that lives. And then yeah, anytime, because we agree that you definitely should be reviewing your board every day to make sure like what needs to be prioritized.
Mhm.
what you have forgotten about, because we are all, especially me, way too guilty of forgetting about things when you don't remember your board. And so definitely I'll remind her where all of that lives as well.
Yeah.
Thank you.
So in the interest of time, let me go to the next slide. So that is ticket result rate. ITBD target is 80% and I see, so this is what you can see. So Phoebe.
Previously, in the previous period, from June 1st to 12th, the number of tickets she has attempted 46 and in that first week and in the second week 66. So in this week, yeah, she consistently has increased her ticket handling.
64 and from 15 to 19th and 59 from 22nd to 26th. Although she needs to bring up her ticket resolve rate. So majorly it is when she needs further troubleshooting and the user is not found, most of these are those tickets.
And same as she was in a different part coming to the ship part, so he is getting lesser of those, you know, those tickets, and so his total number is 39. So, he, I observed he has been consistent on this 40 ticket mark in a week. So, either is 41, 42, or 38. So,
Okay, so I think is it because of the pod difference?
Yeah, it could be the pod difference and things like that for sure. I know until recently, pod 2 has, like the one that Phoebe and I are in, has had one of our larger clients that has now been moved to being a pod 2 and three client because I have upcoming out of office time.
Mhm.
So we are opening up the people who work on this client to pod 3 as well. So that'll also see more tickets. But yeah, pod 2 itself has a lot more people in it who are like multi-role people. So like me and a few of our other like people who are like team leads for various things. So that does lead to being maybe a little bit more tickets in that one at times.
Yeah, so Santos is going to be a part of pod one, I believe.
Correct, yep.
So, Phoebe is part 2 and Shiv is part 3, right?
Correct, yeah.
Alright, so, and every part is, you know, has a separate set of clients that I need to manage, right?
Mostly, yeah, like there's overlap between 2 pods or all three pods at times, but yes, each one has their own dashboard that has all of the clients that is either their pod or an all pod type client.
Mhm.
Great, thank you. So yeah, so despite improvements, so her Phoebe's take a result rate from in 62.61%.
which are, you know, for which I'll work closely with Phoebe so that we can bring this number positively to the higher number, to the higher side. So shifts to that 71.66%. So I've also mentioned total tickets they completed, they worked on and they completed within these two weeks. So Phoebe.
touched 123 tickets and was able to complete 77. You can also review, you know, to your end because this is pure manual data that they enter. So, you know, we have a manual practice here because I do not have personally any access to visibility to your tool.
Mhm.
So what they do is, at the end of the shift, this is a kind of two-minute activity. They enter, they review their ticket, what they completed, what they've worked on, and what was the billable and non-available time on a daily basis. So that, I mean, there's a very less chance of...
A discrepancy at their end.
All right, but in future, we'll see possibility if, you know, I can be granted any access, view only access that I have visibility. I mean, of course, I mean, they should not be costing you any license specifically to assign me that access.
Pre.
Uh.
Yeah, that is committee all about this. Any other observations, Amber, from your end on this part?
No, nothing else.
Thank you. Moving on to the next slides, ITBD service offerings. We have already removed a slide for Build It. That is ITBD's annual event because we got to know that some of your team members have already registered for this event, which is taking place in New
Jersey City Hyatt Regency from 3rd of August to 5th of August. So I'm sure it'll be a nice get together with our ITBD team, senior leadership, C-level executives. Sunny, you know, our business owner, I mean, he is visiting India. He's in our office today. So we had our.
Mhm.
How nice!
town hall with him today. And yeah, so before build it, he decided to visit our India office. And because today we also had RNR in the office. So where he personally distributed prizes to the winners.
We did well in the Q1.
So, that was a nice, you know, get together with him.
Have fun!
So yeah, thank you. So I think you're already aware of the team GPS tools. So this is a homegrown tool. Whenever you have 30 minutes, please do scan this QR code and the team will be right there to give you the demo.
Right, so let us know.
Sounds great.
Yeah, by design, I think this will also be touched more on build it to event. We'll have one specific day covering these tools. So our C-level executives or whoever are going to attend this session from 3rd to 5th.
They will have more insight on these ITBD, you know, services.
Moving on to ITBD holidays.
So nothing much changed. So this is quite a few months from here. Diwali is the festival that Phoebe and Shea both have decided to celebrate. You know that this is one of the biggest festivals. So other holidays, I would say, US holidays specifically, where you need their presence.
So I will request them to accommodate, cover the shift. I can, if there's a requirement, but I would vouch for Diwali. So please allow them to celebrate this festival. And sometimes, you know, as I shared previously, people do.
people who need, you know, who, you know, who are, whose family is not in the same city, but in a different town. So they do.
you know, have some travel plans during those days. So this is a kind of one of the biggest festivals in India.
All right, so lastly, but not the least, so way forward with Uptime USA.
ITBD team and, you know, these three team members, which are now your team members as well, so Santos, Phoebe, and Shiv, we want them to be focused on their KPIs, you know, consistently meeting their targets, and they need to, you know, keep upscaling themselves so that...
****.
Whenever they think there's any gap, or, for instance, just like you shared, Phoebe needs, you know, some maybe training or brush up on email-related issues, so those kind of things we want our engineers to find out on their own, so that, you know, they...
Then everyone knows, you know, once we know our own weaknesses, where we can improve on, I think it's better for everyone.
That's how we grow, because we cannot stay at the same level, you know, every year, every quarter, you know, every year, so we should be moving from one point to the other, you know, every time.
From our end, nothing has changed. I'm sharing the same thing. So my focus would be to continue to encourage and support this team and identify any areas of improvement. If they are not able to find out, you know, it's my job to find out those areas, those gaps, and so that we can
help them grow in this environment.
And of course, okay, so I don't know whether you know, so we have different sites in India.
So I'm speaking from the first site of ITBD that is in Chandigarh. So ITBD started its operation from Chandigarh location, India. So we, Shiv and I, we work from Chandigarh. So Phoebe, she is at the different site.
Mhm.
which is approximately, I would say, 250 kilometers from here. So that's a different, that's NCR. You must have heard New Delhi, that is capital of India.
Mm.
So Phoebe works from that location. So which is why I'm in, so which is why I'm in, she does not sit in the same office. So whenever we have any office get together, if we have an annual event, so Phoebe, we all do join that event and we can get.
Okay.
Pictures clicked and sit together, dance together, but we have when we have some smaller QBRs or monthly events, so sometimes you know it is not that feasible for them to, you know, travel 250 kilometers, you know, from that city to to our hometown city.
Mhm.
and, you know, have lunch or dinner with us. So which is why in the picture, you may not probably see Phoebe joining us, but to this time, you know, we had dinner on this Sunday. But unfortunately, you know, Shiv had, you know, some family emergency.
One of his relatives was admitted to the hospital, so which is why Shiv, you know, in the last minute, he could not attend that dinner party that we had. But I will share that picture with you, you know, how we do celebrate. So one of the team members, I mean, who drove more than 300 kilometers to attend this dinner party.
specifically to join the team. Yeah, that was amazing.
Wow.
And...
Lastly, so that is it from my end, but just hold on, I mean, although I mean.
I do not have a picture of this of.
Show or Phoebe, but let me just show you just one moment.
Let me know once you're able to see my screen.
These are my other, some of the other team members I'm trying to show you.
Nice.
Yeah, so this was a dinner party that we celebrated, you know, in the cafe, which is, which was, I mean...
We live in Tri-City, so...
The names may be tongue-twister for you. This is Chandigarh, Mohti, and Zurichpur. So, I mean, this is a tri-city where we organized this event, and you know, team became a part of it. So, yeah, we we sat for three to four hours together. We...
We ate together, we danced together, and we had a good time.
How fun.
Yeah, thank you. So that was it from my end. Amber, anything from your end? I'm sorry, we are 5 minutes about the time. I mean, but it was really good for discussion with you. We got to know our challenges and the gaps which we need to fill in until we miss next time. But
Anything else from your end before we close this call?
No, I'm good. I made some notes. So I'll schedule a meeting with Phoebe and Javid both this week and just go over a few things with like where they can do their time to make sure they get it all captured like they need to.
All right. Thank you very much. Kevin, anything from your end?
I'm good. Thanks. Thank you, Amber, for your support. And just let Brandy know that we miss her. So maybe we can catch up next week. I'm good. Thank you.
Yeah.
All right, until then, let's meet. I mean, goodbye, and we'll we shall meet next time with some more positive updates. Thank you.